la casa de pía y de karl heinz neubauer
ofrece una vista impresionante de la
central de grohnde y de sus torres de
refrigeración la pareja vive cerca de
este complejo nuclear en baja sajonia
desde hace unos 20 años ya neubauer una
niña de la región todavía se acuerda de
las manifestaciones que acompañaron la
construcción de la central a finales de
los años 1970 aquí en el periódico local
se lee la batalla de chromium era una
gran manifestación pero los
manifestantes no eran de aquí venían de
todo el país después de 35 años de
funcionamiento y de controversia la
central se cerrará este 31 de diciembre
de 2021 los últimos reactores del país
les seguirán el paso dentro de un año
diez años después de la catástrofe de
fukushima el abandono de lo nuclear se
vuelve una realidad en alemania pero
para los neubauer el capitolio está
lejos de acabarse el desmantelamiento
tardará por lo menos diez años incluso
aunque la central ya no esté funcionando
seguirá aquí por un tiempo
la nota además sigue habiendo una cierta
cantidad de riesgos los desechos
nucleares y
entonces el peligro no se descarta pero
hemos aprendido a vivir con la central
hace parte de nuestra cotidianidad
global
pero al final de lo nuclear todavía
causa muchas inquietudes en grande
porque la central representaba una
fuente de ingresos y de trabajo para
esta región cuya economía ahora deberá
diversificar se el alcalde de la
comunidad de emer tal se proyecta hacia
el futuro piensa en un parque de
actividades industriales para compensar
la pérdida de empleos
alrededor de 700 personas trabajan
directa o indirectamente para la central
son personas que tienen buenos salarios
y personas que hacen sus compras aquí
que consumen
es imposible calcular las pérdidas que
esto va a representar para nosotros es
un reto para esta pequeña localidad y
para el conjunto del país porque la
primera economía europea consume mucha
energía para compensar el abandono de lo
nuclear el desarrollo de las energías
renovables ha progresado mucho durante
los últimos 10 años
en 2020 ya representaban un 50 por
ciento del conjunto energético alemán
pero la instalación de nuevas eólicas o
de parques fotovoltaicos se enfrenta
cada vez con más frecuencia a la
resistencia de los locales como aquí en
la región de brandeburgo aquí pueden ver
estas 200 hectáreas de parque que
equivalen a 400 estadios de fútbol y
nuestro terreno está aquí
julian juli se instaló con su compañero
en este terreno hace 10 años ofrece
cursos de equitación según ella esta
actividad está amenazada por la
instalación de un parque solar todo lo
que ven allá eso verde
estará cubierto por paneles
fotovoltaicos
con el acuerdo de la comunidad los
inversionistas tienen previsto instalar
uno de los parques solares más grandes
de la región una pesadilla para julian
olic que sin embargo dice estar a favor
del cambio energético para nosotros el
perjuicio será inmenso pero por ahora no
sabemos nada sobre el impacto que esto
le causará a los animales junto con
otros habitantes del pueblo preparan
manifestaciones para impedir la
construcción del parque una atención que
ilustra
las dificultades de la transición
energética pero la alcaldesa del
municipio está convencida con este
proyecto las generaciones futuras se
verán perjudicadas entonces
necesariamente hay que acelerar el
cambio energético y si el cambio da
miedo pero el status quo no funciona
aunque algunos digan lo contrario
el abandono de lo nuclear está
acompañado por otro objetivo el cierre
de las centrales de carbón por ahora
alemania sigue siendo el principal
productor de lignito del mundo aquí en
el estado de renania del norte-westfalia
la explotación de este carbón
extremadamente contaminante amenaza
todavía a cinco pueblos
deivid 13 en milita desde hace años
contra esta mina a cielo abierto que
está devorando su región natal antes
había 36 pueblos aquí
bosques iglesias todo desapareció al
igual que el militantes que provienen de
todo el país se turnan para impedir la
inminente destrucción de dos pueblos
zacarías tiene 22 años es estudiante
esto consideró que es mi responsabilidad
de estar aquí para impedir que el
planeta sea destruido
david tressens se unió a esta lucha por
convicción pero también porque su propio
pueblo está amenazado su familia vive en
esa pequeña granja desde 1862 un
patrimonio familiar de 14 mil metros
cuadrados con tres caballos y recuerdos
y reemplazables yo sé que tienes hambre
pero no tengo nada ahora tiene su
esperanza puesta en la llegada al poder
de un nuevo gobierno en septiembre
espero que el próximo gobierno con o sin
participación de los ecologistas vote
una ley para proteger estos pueblos no
alcanzaremos jamás nuestros objetivos
climáticos si no renunciamos antes al
carbón y eso significa entonces que
realmente no hay ninguna razón para
destruir estos pueblos es una exigencia
climática compartida por la justicia
alemana
la corte constitucional presionó a
angela merkel ya su gobierno para
realizar una revisión al alza de los
objetivos climáticos alemanes un nuevo
proyecto de ley climático debe ser
presentado en el mes de junio
por ahora el abandono del carbón está
previsto para 2030 y 8